hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the impossible quiz book
chapter 2 you all know the drill by now
so I don't even need to explain anything
let's just get into it
yay all right so I got my brain in
maximum dirt mode so let's just try to
get through this without losing our
minds which is some an impossibility how
many bits in a byte none one 255 or
depends on the size your mouth well
those are all wrong
Hey high score one what you win hello
score whisk Bowl 69 hello score yeah I'm
in it I'm in it I've got the right thing
going on how do you load a ZX lat oh my
god I don't know what that is but I know
what botulism is and it's probably not
that how do you load a ZX slapped rim
load oh I did it
click the oh my god no miss too many
dots yeah yeah yeah
you're really gonna start off with nuts
dunt ah
I saw the dot Oh your son of a [ __ ] dot
dot dot
that's a dot that's a dot dot also dot
dot dot dot oh I thought they were dots
in the bomb define earth moist and which
end it tight ah moist ah [ __ ] no define
Earth okay why is it mostly harmless
define Earth okay what is this the enemy
a power of you all of the above I don't
know if that is it's a square it's a dot
it's a block it's that it's all Oh
anyway ah what what I want it's that
it's that over there that's what that is
it's the dot on the 56 it's a square by
your name it's nothing wait why is it
all of the above which of these is
harmful to Hedgehog crab meat cat food
milk onion ba this is actually real or
our hedgehogs allergic to one of these
things this is actually what we're doing
which of these harmful the hedgehogs why
would they be harmful the head
milk I know in the last game there was a
sonic reference
we're cats an enemy in Sonic we're crabs
in enemy and Sonic maybe I have no idea
how do you win an extra guy
press tab how do you win an extra guy
remove the cartridge and blow in it Oh
apparently not what plan
oh I thought that was gonna be a win
what how do you win an extra guy I would
like to know that because I seem to be
running out of lives very quickly okay
plan sure I think I need to click the
tent flam take tents no no no what do
you want from me how do you win an extra
guy um extra guy dude man a guy who's
running around Mario um I don't know
what I want for me maybe I'm supposed to
give these other things oh no what is
this what does that mean ah I've wasted
it oh yeah all do you win there are
extra guy oh I was here for like five
minutes on that one oh you son of a
[ __ ] I really do have to think outside
the frickin box if you're gonna be shut
that ass okay this is snake what about
whoa what am i doing whoa there are no
instructions I seem to be lost
why how am I supposed to know which one
of these to press oh god how am I gonna
do this no I 259
oh wait no it's time for a floor for
pong what is floor of a pong what are
you talking about
did I I mean I did it I okay nevermind
oh oh god yeah I was terrible at pong
for me I'm not skipping this one son you
made I get a sitter and play pong you're
such an ass
why do I have to play pong you were such
an [ __ ] and I you bastard
thank you Oh bass dude new firmware oh
no this is this this is a trick no this
has to skip step one five one
what happened what shall we play I quite
fancy a game of strip poker
oh well if you had only said so I'd bear
no that's where it won't let you skip
this part you utter ball bag how about
you go [ __ ] yourself
lousy enough did you oh oh I don't know
if you guys can see that but I just
remembered in the beginning there's a
question that's it load no play it
worked
ah words Oh what is that what is Oh boys
are so messed up how many colors in the
spectrum Oh AG BIV in the spectrum ah
[ __ ]
purple ear orange color triangular red
orange and marmalade so that's eight
colors mmm these are all wrong 600 no
why ooh how do I kick arse
Bam Bam Bam bloody but bloody but bloody
huh how do you get rid of the red ring
of death hello bearsy ah ah it takes so
long to get back sure this is what I
think gutter game I don't know get rid
of the red ring no no
oh please miss bouf bouf bouf bouf i
know it has something to do with that
red ring how do I get rid of it what do
i press what do I owe
I just upped it away yay
what is the first book of the Bible
called in Europe in Japan Oh No good
morning mr. Christ I don't know
knobs and hawkers the Megadrive really
what is the name of the prequel the
Metal Gear Solid Oh which plane is
furthest from the Sun uh well I don't
know what are you talking about planted
in our soul oh oh no the bomb
okay so Pluto's not a planet anymore so
it's got to be Neptune yeah there we go
that was actually logical okay carbon
press plus iodine equals blue blue
yellow eggs green hey what is this
residential C c plus AI equals question
how does that equal words loading okay
residential why Oh commercial plus
industrial hey I'm gonna lose my mind oh
god it's a I didn't what what did I do
what happened huh
what happened I just blew up in it took
care of it I think Lowell 69 Don I don't
know what do you want from me what don't
tell me after I click this 69 times if
you do I will be very upset
can you see you son of a [ __ ] you're a
son of a [ __ ]
how am I supposed to play pac-man back
Frank I'm not good at pack Frank man oh
god now Oh No get over me
where are my big power ups I don't have
any powers they're gonna corner me
they're so gonna corner me Oh get out of
here
get out of here daddy are not gonna know
you don't know you don't huh
oh no blue no blue you son of a [ __ ]
I'm not good at pac-man let's play the
feud ok here we go oh god no not off the
bat yeah oh it's a nightmare
ah a nightmare you get out of here get
out here you Bush your boast you most
you moose now oh why why did that happen
I don't know but I don't care I'm okay
I'm okay
what does I'm okay oh my god okay oh how
I know you son of a [ __ ] oh good for
you
the thing you give me multiple lives or
else I would be there
how's this very fast first Oh sides you
I hate you hey you know I hate I hate I
hate no yeah I just noticed it was a big
five that popped up I realized it was
probably important so I'm gonna write it
down whatever okay okay okay okay okay
all right all right all right
fudge all right all right all right
ah wise is working what did that work
mmm I'm never gonna beat you I'm bad at
pac-man oh okay crepe crepe French
French
I'm turning France again I'm turning
frigging French she's gonna run these
guys in the soy cool or they're gonna
catch me this balls ass there's mold in
it no get away
now you red bastard you read [ __ ] you
read [ __ ] huh signals in Dick Wagner put
signals into growlers
I am dead I am going to die ah hey
everything rad fudge it's it's boned
bonerific it's boners tastic got blood
back piss balls ass book back back back
I can't make it cuz I just I did wrong I
did wrong I did wrong I did wrong No
Oh get away from me fine sickles I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I don't
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead yeah
yeah okay France no no no no no you you
know you're new you new new new new yeah
I overloaded my mic so much there it's
not even funny but I don't care I don't
care I don't care I did it I think I won
can I stop now only 20 questions
no I don't want it Oh what am i doing
seven was that important to alright it
down seven though which country produces
the finest plumbers in the world
Mario Italy here we go
Oh duck hunt okay okay okay uh almost
missed that one
no I got him I'll shoot you in the face
no no no I said oh yeah yeah baby first
try that means I have all five my lives
would apparently I'm gonna lose them
anyway good Cuddy hit him all I I don't
think I hit them all all that was one
sneaking down there no oh I got him did
I get him shoot you in the face
no what what did I press I didn't know
how many letters in settlers I don't
know what did I do
I don't know what I did can you tell me
what I did because I do know what I did
I don't want to know what I did yeah
okay you're a trick question you bastard
my brain is in regular mode how many
letters in settlers settlers is an
anagram of letters le TT yes yeah yeah
there's letters and settlers so there's
one one woo 10 plus 10 is 20 unless it's
not that's binary down there are you
talking to this in in binary because
that would be zero one carry the 1 would
be 1 0 0 that would be 1 0 0 in binary
yeah that's a pretty [ __ ] but what the
hell do i do what do I do
Oh what do I go you're not telling me
what I do
ah ah ah
what did I click I think I clicked this
what is the name of the chapter 3 how am
I supposed to know that was that in the
beginning I think I clicked this I did
ok
ba ba ba ba what did I press the attack
I figure type ba switch with the evil
being no no what are you doing this to
me no save me now
why I've spent so much time backtracking
huh I don't know if the evil being is
evil evil evil evil evil evil evil
there's evil enough no wait what no stop
loading save us okay
I'll save you you're a bunch of asses
Fargo good luck yo stop it stop it stop
it stop it stop it stop it hey hey stop
it stop it
summer you're an ass with Shep extort
you need to defeat your glitz salmon no
no
that's a trick you're not real you're
not real an exception of 79s occurred
yog Allah dot exe ha ha ha I'm waiting
oh oh oh wait a minute
Oh who's the man now hey what do I do
well got another game arrow keys to move
up air to jump are to explode why would
I want to explode there we go where am i
oh I'm over here what what is what is
the point of this what is the point of
this god damn it Pam oh [ __ ]
oh I jump on their heads ok yeah hey
poink aaah oh no PAC no I whine pepper
buying Mitch hey come in gonna be buying
bet batch can I make that jump
ah I'm done no more no more I've been
playing this for an hour no more I give
up
I quit it's awful I hate it I hate it so
much I wanna die so anyway that was the
impossible quiz book chapter 2 I saw it
all the way to the end and got the
amazing ending wasn't that fun and
fantastic
haha so if you enjoyed me getting very
angry and now very happy cuz I'm happy
in sunshine and rainbows everywhere let
me know in the comments below leave like
from my stuff ring and as always I will
see you
in the next video bye bye okay all right